[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want that's what the
kids are doing that what are they doing
ready ready ready
oh you don't have me check out our
sponsor thank you to our sponsor up
start-up stars the online lending market
place that provides personal loans using
non traditional variables such as
education employment to predict
creditworthiness upstart believes you're
more than just your credit score they
believe in you and they understand that
they make it fast simple and easy to
check your rate in just a few minutes
the best part is that most people who
are approved get their funds the very
next business day that is crazy the next
day that's great and what would you do
if what if what if what that you had a
personal loan what if I had a personal
loan I would invest in a business that's
cool start a business franchise over
300,000 people have used up start to pay
off credit cards or achieve their
financial goals free yourself from the
burden of high interest credit card debt
by consolidating everything into one
monthly payment with up start that's
right so see why upstart is ranked
number one in their category with over
300 businesses on Trustpilot
and hurry up to upstart dot-com slash
record to find out how low your up start
rate is checking your rate only takes a
few minutes and won't affect your credit
so go ahead and click in our description
box below you get a link that goes
straight there you know what man if
you're out there and you've got high APR
you're paying 26% on your credit card
something is not right you got to lower
that consolidate bring it all together
get us get a lower APR interest rate and
hopefully you get your life together yep
good credit is important it is super
they don't teach you that in school no
they also don't teach you that if you
close a bank account when it hurts
thanks a lot for interrupting my flow I
could have told you that steelo you
gonna go again you're gonna go again
Carlsberg I've never seen somebody hold
it and let it go the same huh you okay
if I don't Bloods gonna come out that's
probably why you're you do get blade no
this because it's so violent that it
literally just think it's like a balloon
that pops at his brain yeah release okay
Steve I want to know what then whoosh
thank you
I hope yeah don't close your bank
account okay so exactly when you get
married when you get married if you
close your bank account because you have
a joint bank account with your wife now
that convene your credit just so you
guys know what why did you decide to do
that because it was easier yeah just
just to blend the count
so do you a third time it's not pretty
competitive I I was petting a dog
earlier not dodging my okay so when you
closed your bank account right um did
you have credit cards tied to that bank
account I have never want to do you just
don't know I don't I don't think that
there are credit cards tied to it no
well I mean I saw what happened and
you're it's nothing bad really it's
because you're not using credit exactly
so the way credit works is you have to
continuously use credit there's a lot of
people out there that are like well I
don't I don't ever use everything cash I
don't ever have credit cards and all
that stuff so they don't build credit so
if you go out and you want to make a big
purchase like at a car or house or
anything like that you have no credit or
if you want where you fat which we run
one through right now you can refine so
because interest rates are so sick right
now so my credit score is it was a seven
[ __ ] thirty five and now it's six
fifty just because I close my [ __ ]
account
that's a row I [ __ ] my credit up when
I was younger I didn't even know I was
[ __ ] it up how did you [ __ ] it up
two ways okay one yeah I had like you
know when you go to the mall and you
shopping I'm like would you like to open
up with Macy's credit card and like
share whatever yeah I cool that a good
discount to do that so I was like cool
I'll get this [ __ ] like 20% off this
jacket to get a lil Macy's credit card
whatever so I had like maybe like two
dollars on this Macy's credit card that
I wasn't I didn't pay off and I was
getting these like people from Macy's
recalling like y'all you're not you
haven't paid your two dollars off and in
my head not knowing how she it works as
like a kid like I don't know fresh out
of high school I was like it's two
dollars okay
I'm saying like what's the big deal I
just kept letting it go like whatever
two dollars I'll handle that whenever
not know why every month I wasn't paying
it it was [ __ ] my credit up right
[ __ ] probably man I was just kind of
like popping to the side like whatever
so I finally called one day I was like
hey all right well what's going on let's
you know pay this off and cancel the
card right so I didn't know my [ __ ] was
[ __ ] up and sucked up so then when I
was leasing my old out II remember I had
the convertible the white one yeah
it followed you all the way up until
adulthood well no here's what happened I
was fine I was fine I was leasing Audi
and then my credit was okay because I
kind of fixed whatever right but then
when my lease was up I was like I love
this car i'ma buy the Audi right so I
took so originally when I was leasing
the payments were coming right out of my
bank account or no it was going to Ali
so I was like cool and then when I
decided I'm gonna buy this car it
started going through Bank of the West
and I didn't know that they changed the
payments from Audi to Bank of the West
cuz now I'm paying the bank instead I
hope because it changed I started
getting these these bills from Bank of
the West and I'm like I never set foot
in the Bank of the West in my life oh
yeah cuz I was like I've never even
looked at a Bank of the West wow I love
how this man has made a million dollars
and this guy manages his finance like a
17 year old [ __ ] idiot no wondering
where you have to pay the Audi what so
that's what happened eventually I was
like what's happening here and now after
I was like maybe like three months late
on this payment you know I'm saying I
finally called to figure it out
I've been after I straighten it all out
I didn't realize how bad my credit was
until I was trying to you know like buy
a house yeah so what the [ __ ] happened
getting the new one yeah when I was
getting the new one oh so so how did you
clear that up did you get you probably
didn't get the best interest rates
because you [ __ ] [ __ ] up pretty much
you know like uh well I was going
through different credit card companies
to try and clear some [ __ ] up because
you know they have those companies that
help you get your credit repaired so I
was kind of I did
and then eventually I got to a point
where someone was like and they looked
at all the other money I had coming in
they're like okay we will approve you
for this [ __ ] thing [ __ ] you were a
maker cuz they probably based it off of
what you were your salary is not your
credit that hell that's a different rate
but see man she came to me do I could
[ __ ] help you I didn't know oh I have
a quick plug Joe Malin academy.com
I just released something on credit
cards too and I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
giving out all this free information
because I feel like it's something
people really [ __ ] need to learn and
they don't teach this [ __ ] they don't
tell you at school and then I think this
is modern day slavery man they get
people [ __ ] in debt they get people
[ __ ] financially and a lot of people
don't want to talk about this [ __ ] yeah
they don't want to talk about it so what
ends up happening is like people are
kind of like embarrassed or ashamed or
they don't know how to deal with it they
don't know where to go but man this is a
fun game I remember living in Koreatown
I live paycheck to paycheck I was like
super ultimately [ __ ] and then I kept
on getting shitty parking tickets
because if you're if you live there you
don't have a driveway so I [ __ ]
figure it out like the signs are
terrible and they're in Korean what they
were terrible they're really bad so yeah
I ended up getting enough tickets
against my [ __ ] that they put a boot on
me so yeah so then so then what happens
when you get a boot on your car - people
don't know this but you basically have
to pay everything in order to get the
boot off you have to pay everything that
you owe and if you owed anything it
doubles every month that's how they get
you man right so but even worse right
you want to get a couple grand right so
to add to that people start to try to
take advantage of your situation because
they can see your situation you have a
big [ __ ] orange boot on your car so
they put signs on your vehicle that says
like you need cash now like will buy
your [ __ ] truck from you so you can
pay off the [ __ ] debt but then you
don't have your car anymore God so yeah
you get all kinds of predatory [ __ ]
[ __ ] going on that's why people just
leave their car there and say [ __ ] it
yeah they could have the car yeah but
even then you still have to pay for it
yeah it ended sending bills you get a
warrant
yeah well cuz you just design you just
just yeah if you're poor you're gonna
get [ __ ] [ __ ] so get this like
okay so when I move right I changed my
address on the DMV [ __ ] the DMV website
by the way for sure
[ __ ] that [ __ ] because online it says
that my address has changed right so
what ends up happening is that my
registration goes to my old address
right and then so I'm driving with old
tags and who the [ __ ] checks their tags
if it's like old or not I get pulled
over I get slapped with a with no
registration bill guess how much that
[ __ ] is with the luxury tax and paying
late to grid eight twelve twelve hundred
no your clothes your clothes mine was
two-year I ended up paying close to 1200
total I paid 900 for that right to renew
it to do all that then so shoutouts to
my cop friend out there he didn't tell
me the right process he says go ahead
and pay the bail so the bail was about
three hundred bucks right I paid the
bail and what I didn't know is when you
pay the bill that's a mission to Gil and
you're done mmm-hmm it's a fix-it ticket
so the way I know it's a shout-out
because this is what he told me to
[ __ ] do pay the bill you come to me
and I'll [ __ ] sign the ticket off so
I saw I signed it too no hop right yes I
saw what a tip is is for people get this
though so you so you sign the ticket off
normal people can do this too you go
into the station you say hey I got my
registration tags can I can I get under
this signed out they'll sign it out
right and then I go to the [ __ ] city
to pay off the [ __ ] it's signed off
and I have to pay 25 bucks trying to go
oh you're you pay the bill you don't
need to do it and I'm like wait so what
am I supposed to do what you would avoid
paying 300 bucks
if you don't pay the bail you go and get
signed that's what a fix-it ticket is
and I'm like [ __ ] man
I only paid 25 bucks yes your friends
get this hit the [ __ ] nerve I said yo
man like I ended up having to pay the
bill like I didn't I didn't have to do
it and he goes why don't [ __ ] deal
with ticket [ __ ]
I don't do that later [ __ ] [ __ ]
hint so later he goes wild oh no I don't
do that petty [ __ ] I don't he's like I'm
a [ __ ] detective I'm all like well
thank thank you for your [ __ ] help
yeah thanks for addressing it in my case
asshat he's the same detective blew up a
[ __ ] shooting range yeah
Delos balusters that was thirteen twelve
twelve thirteen hundred dollars for the
whole process and I had a [ __ ] wait
at the DMV for four hours bro Oh
[ __ ] I got a speeding ticket four
years ago and I went I sent the money in
to pay for it I think it was like $400
or whatever and the court or not court
the the county basically gets back to me
they're like hey you never paid this
[ __ ] so it just doubled and I'm like
what the [ __ ]
so they lost my check I actually went I
went and got it at the post office I got
like it's certified so that I know when
it calls smart man
exactly because I don't [ __ ] with them
them but guess what even when I walked
in there and I have my certification
they wouldn't even check it what and
they're like they're like for all we
know you send us a letter with magic
beans in it I had to pay the double I
had to see I bought a ticket recently on
one Nash [ __ ] I was so excited you're
telling us about it couldn't be one of
the danger Belushi Angela Cora yeah oh
it was so dope it was so dope so I got a
speeding ticket driving back from San
Diego
are we really speeding no and you want
it
[ __ ] you're a boss dude you're about to
go like this and say no versus going it
was so hard it was so difficult yeah
yeah yeah just said yes I'd nod your
head yes anyways so I [ __ ] do the
kids are gone so I got a speeding ticket
and I was like you know what [ __ ] this
because it was like a 600 ticket you
know I'm saying I was like I'm gonna
fight this [ __ ] [ __ ] that because
everyone you know tells you like if you
if you fight the ticket and the cop
doesn't show up they throw it out right
and I've never done that before like let
me see if this you showed up
oh so let me tell you so I win you're
guilty I went and I was like I'm gonna
fight this ticket but then you go to
court the first times and then they ask
you you know I didn't know that's how it
works i sat there if I can wait and
they're like guilty or not guilty
if you say not guilty then they'll
assign you a court date and that's when
you have the court date so I said can
you ask man Joe back to San Diego when
we were shooting the danger boys so I
could go on my court date and I'm like
and I'm like nervous cuz you were like
unprepared you were not speeding and I
still said not guilty I was not I was
not I just why I was not speeding
so I i sat there and i didn't know that
it works like it's like a set time and
then all the people have tickets come at
the same time and yeah all the deputies
come in or whatever the [ __ ] and then I
was sitting there and it was it was
scary because the lady that got called
before me they were like they're like
okay let's say it was an outfit acordes
lets her name was like you know and she
um mom truce like Laura and show these
rights are like Laura anchovies she's
like here and then they called her cop
and he was there in a [ __ ] suit ready
to fight crime and [ __ ] I that lawyer
this - I said that don't get don't do
the date don't show today they give you
the data they gave you switch it again
they are scheduled to knock out all of
their tickets that day so you [ __ ]
try to schedule reschedule twice yeah
and they don't want to come only for you
it's okay do the universe is on my side
okay
you got lucky nice city there and they
called my name I like yep and then they
called the cop and he no one said
anything I was like all right you're
dismissed I was I thought I [ __ ] beat
a murder case dog I feel so good I felt
like oj and [ __ ] you know saying because
i did it so the cop didn't come so the
cop did not show up yeah so I got off
and I left and then me and Ric got some
ramen Sakhalin ramen which is like the
one in them not in this room we don't
know you have innocent man ramen if you
go to the midst wah Japanese markets the
meats watch Japanese market is a ramen
place called um Santa Santa Santa Santa
yeah yeah so [ __ ] bomb yeah it's
pretty good they're like the best day
ever
yeah let's go you couldn't come to
ginger boys after I could no you guys
know you could have come after isn't it
funny how we need 600 dollars sometimes
feel more rewarding than winning
thousands of dollars in doing a Mont
brandy or yes you beat the system
I beat the man-hours the whole process
that's the end all the anxiety had to
deal with command I hate the system
three hours total driving there to San
Diego and back then waiting but going
back to how they [ __ ] the poor people
they [ __ ] middle class and poor people
up so hard doing this [ __ ] why we have
no choice but to try to become rich
people well because when you're rich you
lawyers and you can deal with that and
you're educated so like that's the theme
man is the lack of education like it's
almost like they purposely don't teach
you how like this process works at
school like we're learning about our
founding fathers and [ __ ] and the
government US government we don't know
we don't learn how it operates the
system the teachers are also middle
class too or poor yeah they're probably
in hella debt too I had an English
teacher though he was [ __ ] sick right
he was like I have never paid for a
ticket ever since I learned debating
debating yeah yeah and how he can trap
people like in the cops and then like he
makes it the burden for the cop to prove
there his guilt hmm and he can reword
[ __ ] like that and I'm all like fog this
guy's doh but we didn't learn those
skills he was just trying to tell us he
felt bragging no you know work he was
trying to tell us like how powerful it
is to learn English and debate were you
like [ __ ] UT was he white though he was
white that held
yeah yeah more important than English no
that's not a lie because my buddy
so he's Jewish right and he's told me
that he went to go fight a ticket and
then the court lady was like Schwartz
and he's like yeah and then he's like oh
are you so and so you know so and so and
he's like uh yeah that's so it so I know
this person he's like you're dismissed
hmm let it say yeah that's crazy man cuz
I don't even try to argue with the cops
man I mean not that I [ __ ] like say
I'm like fearing for my life or anything
like that because like you know
obviously like being Asian and pulled
over is is way easier than being wagging
and pull over right but it's like it's
not like I'm trying to argue with any
cops I'm just like I just would rather I
don't even wanna I'm like you know what
yes sir whatever man and then I try to
figure it out afterwards you know I
think the key is not to argue with the
cop the key is to argue in court
mmm so whatever happens during the the
whole thing it's like I just [ __ ] do
what you go that's not true cuz I will
do I do a game every time that I get
pulled over with the cop right reach
over grab his gun okay you got me you
got me you can go to any kind of last a
little bit yeah you could totally get
away if you didn't get their gun then
they respect you indeed they know the
game is on if they see me I see damn
dude I'm white he's white he knows the
game is on and I know the game is off
there's a I usually let you go to give
it good good old green green your
haircut looks nice
thank you I just got it in hair salon
you're looking fly it is thank you very
much yeah I got your flaw Bell Brigade
I'm a sponsored athlete now from barbell
Brigade yeah sponsored commercial so Tim
you just had lunch with Erika Cho I did
our favorite that's my boy Erik Ochoa
doesn't think that I like him true no he
was just like he was telling me he was
like you know what man he's like you
know it's like I know everyone's like
he's like I know I was like kind of new
and like everyone's just kind of like
messing around like I think because like
Steve was making a lot of jokes like I
think Steve might secretly not like me
really so stupid I love Eric I thought
he knows you yeah he does he doesn't
know that you like to [ __ ] around
well hehe I think it's been a minute I
mean I last I saw my was it we're at
your wedding and [ __ ] around to like
that's always my energy with him as we
[ __ ] around with each other right right
it's a one-sided [ __ ] around well that's
true
it's like yeah you know he's not as good
at burning a true yeah he's just that
you know he's a he's like he's a gentle
soul yeah yes he's a big sweet that's my
boy I love him I'm just on the record
now and you're Jay we're talking
whatever we want and I just wanted to
say I love you
there you go there you go she's clear
another blade Steve super nice I don't
know how people see them as mean I think
people just take it differently like
like people don't joke around with you
because they don't want you to do it
back true that can happen it's like
that's what he made a magician cry and
that's one of the funniest things I've
ever you made a magician cry this story
is so [ __ ] [ __ ] it doesn't and I
said [ __ ] I'm sorry no this this
story's having me saying this time
listen I when I treat what I hang out
with my friends they break balls right
yes I was just reading this got like my
friends and I made this brain lovely
obviously but I just you know I just
miss judge not everybody's your friend
Brett know this position is definitely
not my friend
[Music]
[Music]